[Music]
this is sky news live in calais for a
special program on the deaths of 27
people trying to cross the english
channel
15 man overboard
sky news obtains audio of the mayday
call from the french coast guard made
during yesterday's disaster
a shock but not a surprise the home
secretary says there's no quick fix to
the migrant crisis with uk officials
traveling to france tonight
despite the disaster more boats arrive
in kent with this month the busiest ever
for channel crossings
president macron asked for more help
from the uk amid claims that france
isn't doing enough to prevent the
crossings
and the full scale of the issue is
revealed as uk asylum claims hit their
highest level for nearly 20 years and
deportations are almost halved
[Music]
hello and good evening from calais in
northern france where just off the coast
27 people drowned yesterday as they
tried to reach the uk
the french president says his country
needs more help to stop the channel
crossings with the home secretary priti
patel calling for joint patrols of the
french coast government sources say uk
officials are traveling to france
tonight but yesterday's deaths couldn't
prevent others attempting the crossing
today with dozens more people reaching
kent
and this afternoon the body of another
man was found on a french beach it's not
yet known if he was connected to
yesterday's incident
our europe correspondent adam parsons
has our lead report tonight on the
migrant crisis
it began with a distant sighting and a
desperate mayday call
me
15
men overboard approximately 15 man
overboard
when rescuers arrived this was all that
was left of the boat a twisted piece of
deflated plastic adrift in very cold
water
was one of the first people there he
pulled a series of bodies from the water
within hours he was back at work with
the calais lifeboat crew
still affected by his view of a hellish
disaster
[Music]
um
but still people attempt this perilous
crossing here gathered together at
calais main train station dozens of
migrants who had tried and failed to
cross the channel
these people are soaking wet they're
covered in mud and they're wearing
drenched life jackets this is evidence
that even in the wake of tragedy there
is still a long stream of people
desperate to cross from france
over to the united kingdom
these people are living in camps and in
rough shelters there is no comfort for
any of them their one aim is to cross
the channel
we meet hassan aware of the tragedy but
still wholly focused upon reaching the
uk
i heard the news my life to be very
honest
by myself i don't care about others
because it's my own life
even i see the water i can swim if i put
my wasp in my jacket i can swim honest i
want to go to uk because my life is
there will be very good
this camp is cold and miserable the
effects of cross-channel migration can
be seen in both britain and france and
both countries think the other one
should be doing more the french have
called for a meeting of ministers in
calais on sunday and today speaking in
croatia the french president urged
greater action
foreign
has become synonymous with migration and
political rows that seem to go nowhere
this town and its people are weary they
will continue to to to die in the sea or
under the tracks
the the the situation is deadly they can
also die off of the cold
the police operation here continues
so many people have predicted this
disaster now nobody can say that it
won't happen again adam parsons sky news
kelly
well adam joins me now from songkat just
along the coast from me and everybody
digesting that awful news yesterday adam
so what will the impact be of
yesterday's events
well i think it's a fascinating cocktail
of things for one thing we have for so
many years talked about the impact and
the management of migration this beach
songgat of course has been right at the
center of that so many small boats have
left here to try to get over to the
united kingdom and i think it during
that time this cross-channel migration
has been talked about pretty much
entirely in terms of of politics and
party politics and policy
and geopolitics and almost this
political battle between the united
kingdom and france i think what has
happened here awfully suddenly is that
this has been personalized we know that
27 people went out there into the
channel and have died tonight it is cold
and windy the channel is an inhospitable
place let's make no mistakes that was a
horrible way to die and people who are
thinking about this now i think will
reflect on those people and the lives
that they have lived the families they
leave behind that may change the public
perception
of migration i think a second impact may
be in that political battle between the
uk and france it has undoubtedly now
earned more urgency more pace both sides
in a sense trying to take the initiative
but i would urge a certain amount of
caution here i think there's a chance
that both will still double down on
their positions the uk will demand the
french do more there is clearly a point
to be made on that i myself on the beach
very near here i've seen migrants
running down carrying a boat past french
police officers but the french believe
that the uk should do more thirdly and
finally the migrants themselves there
are still so many people around here
who've come to northern france intent on
getting over there to britain will their
minds be changed by these deaths i don't
think so
adam parsons live there on the beach at
tsongat thank you while the home
secretary has told mps that yesterday's
disaster was a dreadful shock but it
wasn't a surprise pretty patel said
there is no quick fix to the migrant
crisis saying authorities need to break
up the criminal gangs and their supply
chains and address what she called the
pull factors which makes so many people
want to risk the channel crossing uk
officials are traveling to france
tonight with ms patel expected to visit
on sunday where sky's political editor
beth rugby reports now on the political
solutions to this crisis
i had a whole watch of hair in my mouth
in that
it is our mission and objective to break
this route up
i think the most important thing is to
stop them coming
across from france so we're working very
closely with the french authorities
we have to stop that we have to stop
people's lives being put at risk
the rhetoric versus reality for years
this political pair have promised to
take back control of immigration but the
failure to deliver now unfolding into
human tragedy
the home secretary to the commons to
explain what happened yesterday was a
dreadful shock it was not a surprise but
it is also a reminder of how vulnerable
people are
put at peril when in the hands of
criminal gangs and the government's
latest plan to solve it no quick fix
this is about addressing long-term pull
factors smashing the criminal gangs that
treat human beings as cargo and tackling
supply chains
this requires a coordinated
international effort patients running
out on the back benches
we cannot wait on the french cooperating
with us and take these poor people back
as they should we have to act now in a
national emergency to save lives people
who voted to take back control have
every right to ask the question if you
can't protect the integrity of the
borders what can you control
the government's been scrambling to find
a solution to this crisis none have
worked proposals to push back boats in
the channel unrealistic changes to the
asylum system bogged down by legal and
political opposition the people
smugglers the traffickers have got a
real hold on these desperate people we
need to break that
i'm also frustrated that home secretary
makes no end of headline grabbing
statements but isn't doing anything to
deal with this
effectively we need to work in the camps
and upstream with the french authorities
to prevent this kind of tragedy
the home secretary spoke to her french
counterpart today to offer joint patrols
and uk officials are traveling to france
tonight for emergency meetings but
tensions between the countries are
running high
there's real anger in government towards
the french with one senior minister
telling me today that they found it in
their words shocking that the french
authorities hadn't been doing more to
try to stop people boarding these small
boats but officials also tell me that
there is now hope at least that this
tragic loss of life will spur
governments into taking real action but
the bigger problem of how you stop tens
of thousands of people fleeing their
homes to try to find sanctuary in europe
that is so much more difficult to
resolve
years of promising fixes but this a
global problem that needs countries to
work together
beth rigby sky news
well beth joins me now from westminster
and high level meetings then planned
beth between the french and the british
to what end
well anna there's a couple of things
going on there's the short-term measures
that both countries will look to take
and then the longer more thorny issue of
how you begin to try to begin
to tackle this problem but in terms of
the short term
trying to resolve it
officials british officials are
traveling over to france tonight where
they'll have technical talks uh with
french counterparts on some of the
measures that they can begin to
implement immediately to try and tackle
this issue and stop people making that
dangerous crossing across the channel to
hit the shores of great britain and
what has the uk government offered well
it's offered to do joint patrols across
the channel it's offered to send border
force and police to help
patrol
the beaches in the past france has said
it doesn't want that assistance around
issues of its own sovereignty
but those offers are on the table and
officials will now discuss those on
sunday we expect pretty patel to make
the journey over to france where we
expect that she will have a ministerial
meeting
with her counterpart in france and at
that point i suspect there will be some
sort of announcement to make about what
the two governments have agreed
in the short term to try and really bear
down on these traffickers to bear down
on people taking this dangerous crossing
this deathly turn this tragic loss of
life really focusing the minds about
trying to stem at this problem in the
short term but in the longer term as the
home secretary said in the commons today
it's a very intractable problem it
requires global coordination yes the
government are putting through a bill in
parliament to try and make it less
attractive for people to take illegal
routes uh to the uk to try and uh begin
to dismantle these human uh trafficking
chains but they also need cooperation
not just with france but with the eu and
more widely and that is going to take
more time but in the short term
the focus is on the channel but in the
longer term it's on how to begin to it's
tackle
these
terrible human trafficking gangs
beth will be live in westminster thank
you and uh while beth was talking
actually we had confirmation from pretty
patel that she was indeed traveling to
france for those discussions on sunday
well that story will i'm sure featuring
tomorrow's newspapers we'll have our
press preview from 10 30 this evening
and that is with tonight's news
tomorrow's headlines joining us will be
the columnist carol malone and the
political editor of the liverpool echo
liam thorpe that is from 10 30.
well despite the deaths of 27 people off
the coast of calais yesterday dozens
more people reached kent today in
previous years the autumn month saw a
big drop off in the number of people
making that crossing but this year with
much calmer conditions in the channel
until now
record numbers have made the journey it
suggests that crossing the channel in a
boat is now seen as the most viable
option for reaching the uk regardless of
the time of year
sky correspondent laura bundock reports
now on the people smuggled at sea
it is exceptionally busy on the waters
around dover
matt coker knows the channel well he
also knows its dangers
he was at sea when the frantic mayday
call came in
as soon as i heard it i i knew it was
going to be very serious uh whenever you
hear the call mayday people in the water
you know that it's it you know it's a
it's an all-out sort of sprint for
people to get there
to rescue them
border force is stepping up patrols with
jet skiers out early
and a spotter plane overhead
so to give you a sense of the extra
patrols border force are putting on
there's a small rib out on the water at
the moment it's scanning and searching
close to the shoreline looking for those
smaller boats
but with the winds worsening it's
unlikely more are coming
these are some of the last to arrive
picked up overnight and lucky to have
made land
the desperate victims of conscienceless
criminals
we found networks of smugglers selling
routes into europe
even claiming their journeys are safe
matt coca says the gangs are noticeably
more organized
you know when it first started it was
very it seemed just disorganize scramble
across the channel really i mean people
used to grab anything that floated and
and they would have a go to get across
but now it seems a well-oiled machine
they're using these large
dinghies which are purposely made for
for one-time use just to transport
people across the channel
we showed matt the dinghy that sunk
i think the dingy's been overloaded and
it's broke up underneath them so it was
the sheer weight the ship
yeah and also the poor quality of the
way the dinghy's been made
this is the reason why so many people
try to cross the channel on wednesday
then the sea was like a piece of glass
now the weather has really changed and
there is no way you would want to
attempt this journey on these waves in a
dinghy
the channel will be rough for days
but once the weather calms everyone
knows the crossings will continue
laura bundock sky news dover
well let's just bring you the very
latest statement that we've had from
pretty patel a statement she said
following the home secretary and the
french interior minister meeting on the
channel incident the home secretary the
readout says spoke to her counterpart
minister gerald dominar to express her
sadness
at the tragic
incident which led to at least 27 deaths
in the channel and to put forward plans
for greater collaboration and innovation
she said in stopping these deadly
crossings she expressed deep regret that
despite increased french patrols
surveillance and intelligence sharing a
significant number of boats are still
able to make it through police lines the
ministers underlined the need for deeper
cooperation on stopping the channel
crossings and the need the statement
says to work closely with european
partners the home secretary made a clear
offer to france in terms of joint french
and uk cooperation and joint patrols to
prevent these dangerous journeys from
taking place she offered to work with
france to put more officers on the
ground and do absolutely whatever is
necessary to secure the area so the
vulnerable people do not risk their
lives by getting into unseaworthy boats
something which the french have always
put off because of sovereignty issues
the statement though continues the home
secretary will meet with minister
dominar this weekend to further this
work and she will send officials and law
enforcement
officers to paris tomorrow to intensify
joint corporation and intelligence
sharing both ministers agreed to remain
in touch uh so that is the very latest
on that so certainly a meeting tomorrow
to intensify joint corporation and
intelligence sharing and that meeting as
we reported on
sunday
well new figures released today by the
home office have revealed the scale of
the issue
the number of uk asylum applications is
at its highest level since 2004 higher
even than the peak of the migration
crisis in 2016. more than 37 000
applications were made in the year to
september 2021 relating to more than
forty four thousand people
of those thirteen thousand two hundred
and ten were accepted that figure is
down by more than a third compared to
pre-pandemic levels
analysis by the refugee council suggests
that 61 of people who arrive in the uk
by boat will be allowed to stay
but in the year ending june 2021
deportations from the uk
fell to 2910 that is down 44 on the
previous year and a government minister
has admitted that of the more than 25
000 people who have crossed the channel
this year just five
five have been deported
well alex rossi reports now on what is
being called a broken system
peering out and tracking the sea for
migrants juliette wolford sees herself
as part of a new home front defending
the coast
would you like to tell me why you're
here video cameras are also part of the
armory
she and other activists are angry at the
constant arrival of boats
i would like to see a proper secure
process
if these people are running from war
i think then we need to help them
but there are a lot of the migrants that
are not running from war
everyone here including juliet is
shocked by this tragedy but many agree
with what she's saying
but others are not so sure
a short distance away on another cliff
sits k marsh from channel rescue
her volunteer group checks the weather
and alerts the coast guard to any boats
in distress
the tragedy in the channel was an
accident waiting to happen there are a
lot of people that do really care and
they do want to promote this welcoming
in dover they're just frightened because
it is a very controversial issue we need
to see these people as human beings who
are fleeing death destruction poverty
and war
they may be two women a few miles apart
but their reactions to what they've been
witnessing over the last few years
could not be more different
but they do agree on one thing the
government's handling of this crisis has
been disastrous
and more will die at sea without a
solution
the chaotic arrival of migrants on the
beaches along the kent coastline is
likely to become an even more divisive
problem in the months to come in this
community it's already a toxic and
polarizing issue
and the optics of all this for the
government could well become a political
liability it's all extremely damaging
for a party that campaigned on taking
back control and sovereignty
at the heart of all this are of course
the migrants nearly 26 000 arriving in
the last year
some stay at this former military
barracks in foxton
ushang ibrahimi is typical of the asylum
seekers we meet an iranian kurd who
converted to christianity he tells me he
faced death threats and had to flee
was dangerous for my life something is
coming dangerous to my life
you were scared to stay in iran yes it
was like this
it's clear to many here that the home
office is failing to deal with the
numbers claiming sanctuary
this is a problem entirely of the home
office's own making there is enough
accommodation the problem is is that
asylum claims not being processed
quickly enough by the home office they
should take six months they're taking 18
months minimum
in the seaside towns on the front line
of this crisis people are fed up with
the government's response
the home secretary may say the asylum
system is broken but what they want to
know here is why hasn't she fixed it
alex rossi sky news dover
well let's go now to dover and ashna
hernage is live for us there and despite
the increased patrol all the focus today
on this crossing ashner
once again people are still making the
journey
that's right anna despite this tragedy
yet more boats are leaving the french
coast and arriving here in kent much to
the concern the bafflement and the
frustration of many people
in this part of the world they can't
comprehend just the numbers the sheer
number of people involved already this
morning we saw some 40 people arrive in
two of those rubber dinghies a child
among them they boarded a red
double-decker bus but you'd wonder they
have spent months traveling from places
like iran iraq kurdistan and now they've
arrived here in the uk was it what they
thought it'd be and so begins their
claim for asylum they could be waiting
up for two years before their
application is processed and it is in
fact quite a miracle really that they
have managed to make this journey across
it is freezing here in dover it's
freezing out in the channel it's also
incredibly busy someone described it to
me as crossing making that crossing
being like as though you're crossing a
three-lane motorway on foot but also
there is no sense of direction for the
people that are driving these boats
there is no driver it's simply hoping
for the best and those boats are so
crowded so how do you tackle this issue
when human beings are being treated like
cargo in the words of the home secretary
pretty patel today
what is clear is that this problem isn't
going away crossings this month in kent
have been the busiest they have been
since it all began clearly this tragedy
has not been a deterrent
i shouldn't hurry live there in dover
for us thank you very much indeed well
you're watching our special program live
from calais tonight coming up we'll be
speaking to a charity worker here in
calais who helps support the refugees
about what can be done to stop people
risking their lives to cross to the uk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please just make that first move and
they've come in firing again
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across gansu
[Music]
that's what's left of the north tunnel
where the north koreans exploded five
nuclear
warheads
and this is a show of strength at a time
when china is more fragile than it has
been at any time in recent years
from that explosion so you can see it
littered along all the way we take you
to the heart of the stories that shape
our world
the train station the airport they're
both closed we're not sure about the
roads we've seen reports that they are
being blocked by police so we're going
to try and find a way out
after five days stranded here this is
deliverance we help you understand the
world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
one more now on our top story and the
deaths of 27 people trying to cross the
channel it's expected that the number of
migrant crossings taking place will
reduce as winter weather sets in but
yesterday's calm conditions encouraged
dozens of people to try to reach the
kent coast and november has been the
busiest month on record with more than 6
000 migrants having reached the uk
despite the colder weather
well joining us now is maya conferti
from loberge de migrant who work with
refugees and displaced people in calais
and across northern france providing
food and support very good evening to
you maya and because you work with these
people day in and day out what was your
reaction when you heard of so many dead
in that tragic incident yesterday
it is completely tragic it is however
something that we expected we knew that
was bound to happen one of these days
that the boat would capsize and uh and
no help could be rich in time so we
expected it but uh but uh
it makes us uh so incredibly sad but it
also makes us very angry
and we hear the uk government and the
french government talk only you know put
all the blame on the smugglers we know
that
what
the
many people
admire
i think your line is breaking up a
little bit continue sorry
so so
you know the the the there's too many
people in the boats the engines are too
small and so forth
but uh uh the the the blame starts in uh
in the crisis of welcome that we have uh
in in the uk and and in france you uh
you know we we have to welcome those
people we have to be able to look at
their asylum requests the people who are
in calais and want to the uk
go to the uk they cannot ask for asylum
in france because they have fingerprints
taken elsewhere
and so we we
change those
yesterday we spoke to a smuggler in fact
in northern iraq they say they buy these
boats they're supposed to fit five
people they strengthen them with metal
rods they fit 15 to 20 people in and
they make good money doing it you know
this is a trade for them do you think
it's right that the focus is on those
gangs those people smugglers as the
british and french governments are
discussing today
well i mean obviously uh you know
they're the
smugglers are pushing things to make as
much money as possible and and that's
not okay you know
uh definitely not but the blame is not
on the smugglers they are smugglers
because there is no legal way to go to
the uk because the people cannot even
ask for asylum in france either so
that's why they're smugglers smugglers
respond to a need that the refugees have
to
go from one place to another because the
borders are closed because there's walls
because there's barboir because the the
border is uh locked up if the if the
border was more open if there were legal
ways for people to cross people would
not make use of the smugglers it would
you know it's a lot of money on top of
that for them to spend if they spend
that money is because they have no other
choice so we need to have more legal
ways and more welcoming of the refugees
and there won't be any more smugglers
it is bitter here in uh in northern
france uh people still keep coming we
know the french authorities take down
the makeshift camps
yesterday we heard reports that they
took off sleeping bags from families uh
what do you feel about when you hear uh
you know news like that what assistance
do you give people and
their desperation if i can put it like
that
we we see that we see that every day you
know this is this happens uh there's an
eviction in every camp happening every
day or every other day the government
does
uh stride this last few years of making
basically life as unbearable as possible
in calais for the refugees with the the
idea that they'll be discouraged and
will not stay clearly it's not working
at all uh people live in absolutely
horrible conditions like you say you've
seen them yourself
and we are scandalized by that but it
does not make people not come to calais
because they want to go to the uk
because that's their last hope and any
human being
who is pushed to isen will just keep on
going until he dies and if they must
risk their lives to cross the sea uh
they will risk their lives because uh
life it in cali is unbearable anyway
and if you had one solution what would
it be um a safe route to the uk
a safe route to the uk or
get rid of the agreement of le 2k you
know this border today as the british
border has nothing to do uh being in
france it should be in the uk especially
that the uk is not part of europe
anymore uh there's got to be a change in
the doubling regulation so that people
will have fingerprints you know this
whole fingerprints the regulation does
not make any sense
you arrive in europe in hungary you have
your fingerprints taken and that means
you will not be able to ask for asylum
in france or germany uh that's a
ridiculous thing that needs to be
changed so it's the it's all those rules
about welcoming refugees that need to be
changed and another thing is uh since
the brexit miners no longer can be
reunited with their families in the uk
that's completely blocked we need to
reopen that i mean a child a teenager 14
15 years old who has family in the uk
should be allowed to go into the uk and
it's no longer it's no longer possible
since the brexit so there's definitely
ways to change uh things and it doesn't
i mean i'm not saying we shouldn't stop
the smugglers but not you cannot put all
the emphasis on that there's those
regulations i spoke about really need to
be reviewed
it it sounds like it's a it's a long
list from your point of view isn't it
from lebron
thank you very much indeed
it's not a long list well i'm going to
speak to a politician soon we'll put
those points to them definitely maya
thank you very much indeed we're still
to come here from calais we will be
speaking uh two politicians an mp for
calais an ngo charity worker and the
chair of the all party parliamentary
committee on migration for their
perspective from both sides of the
channel as calls are made for greater
cooperation
well france says it is mobilizing
reservists now and beefing up its sea
rescue operations following yesterday's
incident president macron has defended
efforts to tackle migrant crossings but
with pictures emerging of french police
watching on as more boats entered the
channel yesterday there is concern that
the french authorities aren't doing
enough to prevent another disaster
well sky correspondent stephen murphy
reports now on the french response
on a beach near calais police find an
outboard motor possibly abandoned by
people smugglers but there's also a real
struggle to prevent migrants from
reaching these beaches in the first
place
the french border police has stepped up
its checks on the frontier with belgium
up to 60 percent of migrants looking to
cross the channel enter france across
this border
the man in charge of trying to stop that
is keen to point out their successes
france has stepped up policing actions
but some of the tactics seem
self-defeating
this patch of wasteland here in dunkirk
illustrates what the french police are
up against just over a week ago up to
1500 migrants were camped out here on
this patch of ground then in a dawn raid
french police swooped and cleared the
site leaving just the detritus you see
here
but the migrants decamped and set up a
new base here on these disused railway
tracks just a mile up the road
here we meet an iraqi kurd sanger ahmed
he previously lived in britain for four
years and is now trying to get back he
says the police have cracked down on the
migrants
as i hear from the uk government giving
more more uh spending more more
investment and giving a given to the
french french authorities to make the
border secure and secure so so that's
why police taking our tents and sleeping
base from one and displacing
us from one place to another every day
france is deploying more police on its
border with belgium but there's so much
money to be made in trafficking that
people will continue to take their
chances buy land as well as see
stephen murphy's sky news on the french
belgium border
well let's discuss what can be done with
conservative mp david simmons chair of
the all party parliamentary group on
migration and pierre henry dumour the mp
for calais welcome to both of you uh
david simmons let's start with you this
has become so political of course many
mps really fearing how the public back
in the uk are reacting to this the home
secretary solution seems to be to cut
this off as a route to the uk but that's
not the solution is it
what happened yesterday was something
we'd all feared for a very long time
and if there's anything positive to come
out of it we must hope that as the death
of ireland kurdi did on the shores of
the mediterranean in 2015 it results in
a serious change in the way that we
approach this we have to change the
business model of the people's muddlers
so that people are not putting their
lives at risk in the english channel and
a point many of the parliamentarians
have made and which is contained in the
new nationality and borders bill is to
change the way the people who are
seeking asylum in the uk do that so they
have a safe and legal route by which
they can come
rather than being in the hands of people
smugglers who care little for their
lives and which has resulted now in this
appalling tragedy
say a safe and legal route like what i
mean some charity suggesting that it
should happen at embassies around the
world but
no government wants that how would you
suggest a safe route could be made a
workable at present you can't claim
asylum in the uk unless you're
physically here
whereas in the future we could look at a
combination of embassies and consulates
digital platform and also work with the
united nations high commission for
refugees who as they very much did in
the syrian resettlement scheme would be
able to identify people who were asylum
seekers with a valid claim and then
joined them up with a country that was
willing to take them and under that
route both the uk and many other
countries in europe and across the wider
world manage the resettlement of
refugees without lives being lost and
with the communities that were receiving
those people knowing from the outset
that they had a valid legal claim and
that they were going to become long-term
members of that community
well that's the the long-term possibly
the medium-term solution in the meantime
in the beaches to the south of here
they're still trying to get across we've
got a storm coming in obviously that's
presumably why it was so busy yesterday
so to the mp for cali then pierre henry
dumour the british newspaper is full
today of the image of a french police
vehicle standing by watching dozens of
migrants once again getting on yet
another boat i mean is the truth of it
that it's better for northern france if
these people get on a boat and get to
the uk and don't stay here
you know the french police forces are
doing whatever they can to stop these
migrants to cross i saw these pictures
myself and i can assure you because i
talked to people not just one on picture
but
french police officers
that it was not possible to intervene
you had 50 migrants and two or three
police officers
so even if they went there what should
what could they have done
like taking their guns out try to shoot
at them
um that's not possible clearly it was
not possible to intervene and to stop
them to go at sea
and the fact is
these migrants
want to go to the uk and they will not
stop trying to go to the uk
because that's their dream and that's
why they they paid for
uh from the homeland from the departure
so basically we can do whatever we can
we can have more and more technology we
can have more and more police officers
we can have
we may have more
and more fences or wires etc etc it
won't change
because the smugglers plus the migrants
will find a way to cross and to to
achieve the journey in the uk and as
long as we are
trying to address the consequences of
migration and not the causes
of migration we will face
such awful drama as we faced yesterday
and
we must do everything we can left side
of the channel
not to to transform the channel into a
new graveyard
well mr simmons uh people watching this
at home will simply be saying why do we
make it so easy for them why is it like
a taxi service the border force the rnli
picking these people up they get halfway
they turn off the the boat engine it
becomes a search and rescue and they're
picked up and it's job done i mean the
same happened off the coast of libya and
in the end the eu stop charities from
going to the coast of libya to to
collect refugees and migrants from there
so what can be done about the the the
optics of this really for the british
electorate
pierre is absolutely right in describing
the situation in france it's a very
tough ask for the french police to
monitor many miles of coastland
coastline many of which is
remote beaches and things like that i
think the
issue for the united kingdom is going to
be working with frontex which is the eu
border agency which has had a lot of
success in the mediterranean in taking a
number of measures including pushbacks
which have been very controversial in
the uk which is undertaken between
greece and turkey as a means of
interdicting the people smugglers and
frontex is now becoming much more
engaged so that we see
vessels not just from france but from
from the netherlands from belgium from
spain from denmark other countries with
an english channel coast and we need to
make sure that the uk coast guard and
our border force cutters are able to
work closely with them so when the
french police see as we saw those
pictures the french police see a vessel
that's putting to sea it's able to be
intercepted swiftly those people
then returned to the nearest safe place
and then dealt with appropriately and
france takes many more asylum seekers
than the united kingdom but we need to
ensure that those who come and three
quarters who arrive in the uk are
successful in having a legal claim here
under our laws but we need to make sure
that people are put off and putting
their lives in the hands of people
smugglers because it ends in tragedies
like the one that we've just seen
uh monsieur are we do more we've just
spoken to um an ngo a charity worker who
works with the refugees here and says
every day the authorities here break up
those makeshift makeshift camps destroy
the tents even take off sleeping bags
off people it is bitterly cold here as
you well know
how do you feel when that happens does
it bring you shame that uh that we and
you are treating people like that
no it's not breaking me ashamed because
we've got what the
the
the the
leader of the ngo said uh was not
totally true she didn't mention that we
have
two thousand empty places in shelters
away from calais for these people and
these places two thousand places are now
empty
and some of the ngos in calais
say to the migrants don't go to these
governmental funded shelters stay in
calais stay in the mud stay in the hands
of
smugglers try to cross
that's not possible we need to have all
the migrants in calais to go to the
facilities we built for them
hundreds of kilometers away from calais
and
we need to deal with the uk to have a
legal route for other seekers the fact
is
to apply for asylum in the uk you need
to have both feet in the uk so it means
to apply for asylum in the uk you need
to go and to cross the channel with uh
smugglers that's not possible because uh
to apply for asylum it means you you you
need to take a risk to die in the
channel so we need to
to to create
some kind of new asylum application
for migrants to apply for asylum while
they are in continental europe and not
only when they are
fully in the uk if you take a look at
the figures in 2019 so the the last
normal year pre-covered
the uk processed i think 30 000 as they
do applications while friends processed
the same year four times more one
hundred and twenty thousand asylum
application for quite the same number of
inhabitants so you see there is a
problem right there and the fact is the
migrants in cali
are not uh applying for asylum in france
because they think they're gonna have a
chance to apply for islam in the uk
which is not the case
because um
once
they don't apply for us
legal work
apologies for uh for interrupting you we
must end it there thank you very much
indeed uh pierre henry dumour mp uh for
calais and david simmons two
conservative mp and chair of the all
party parliamentary group on migration
thank you very much indeed and clearly
much for the uk and french authorities
to discuss in the coming days well
asylum seekers now settled in the uk
many of whom faced a perilous journey
themselves have been shocked by
yesterday's tragedy
while sky correspondent lisa holland
reports now on a community's despair
the asylum community has been rocked by
the disaster in the channel this
accommodation in liverpool houses people
now in the asylum process
almost all took their lives into their
hands to make the same journey and
survived
vadurmani is from iran and arrived four
months ago he says everyone is talking
about the ill-fated crossing i was very
sad about that prepared that people had
family that people had father mother
baby all of all of us
you know
we said it means it will be it will be
maybe happen for one of all of us if we
came with both yeah you mean it could
have been you yeah
mitra merad from iran is thought to be
the first person who died trying to
cross the channel in a small boat
she perished two years ago these photos
were taken in paris days before she
attempted the journey
i think we just lost a beautiful soul in
search of of greater beginnings
we spoke to her friend delvinisia in
south africa she studied with mitra in
thailand and is angry smugglers are
still cashing in on the desperation of
migrants
so my fear is that if nothing is done
we are going to continue with mitra's
story
throughout the years
anger
frustration would be a good way of
describing it um
but also defeat
you know like like you've won
you know
and i've gone
he's one
the smugglers
but those who work with asylum seekers
say many don't understand how dangerous
the crossing is
there's a temptation to look out from
france and to be able to see who you're
trying to get to
but they probably don't realize it's one
of the it is the busiest busiest
shipping lane in the world
they don't realize about the tides
there's lots of factors that they won't
know about
but people are driven
to get to a place
people have families here they have
connections ties they speak the language
britain is the hoped for final
destination for many migrants who set
off in search of a new life but it's
feared even the deaths of so many in the
channel won't dissuade others from
trying to get here lisa holland sky news
liverpool
well sky news understands that kurdish
people were among those who died in the
channel yesterday the kurdish government
has appealed to the uk and the eu for
help in stopping migrants leaving iraq
and fully victim to people smuggling
gangs wisconsin middle east
correspondent aleister bunkel joins me
now from ubial in northern iraq and
alastair i know that you've spoken to
refugees there you've spoken also to a
smuggler and certainly large numbers of
people who end up here in calais in
northern france say that they've come
from where you are
yeah they have it is a problem not just
for the british and for the french and
and wider europe but it is a problem for
officials here as well they know that
they are the source of the problem they
understand why well certainly within the
wider region a lot of people want to
leave the middle east and try and find a
safer more peaceful life
in europe whether it be because of
conflict or discrimination over perhaps
their sexuality or perhaps their
religion
but they want to work with british and
european authorities to try and stem the
tide of people leaving to go into europe
from the source itself and we've
interviewed a representative from the
kurdistan regional government this
evening and he's basically made a plea
to the british and to the europeans you
know help us
the network of smugglers it's really
huge and they get actually
they're motivating those people to leave
at the same time the government has done
things which is like
to prevent those smugglers but at the
same time more is coming as well krg is
open for any help will be like if it's
like from european union countries uk or
any other country
he also confirmed to us that they are
sure that some of the dead are kurdish
they don't know how many they don't know
the identities they're working to try
and establish that working with the
french working with the british
it is
desperately sad but i have to be honest
it's no surprise that kurds were
involved there are a lot of them where
you are anna
alastair bunker live there in obeal
thank you very much indeed we're plenty
more live from calais throughout the
evening more reaction to the events of
yesterday